yeah oh my god I'm gonna send this to my
mom no problem so today I am playing
game where I'm gonna try to figure out
who is drunk I think I'm pretty good at
telling when someone's drunk and when
someone's not drunk I can usually tell
by people slurring their words or
looking off into the distance at like in
Nice gaze I could tell by their demeanor
the way they talk and the way they moved
your movements a little more like still
but like not exactly like frantic either
obviously I don't know the people I'm
gonna be hanging out with today so this
will be interesting
nope I'm not drunk unfortunately I am
not drunk right now I am NOT drunk no
I'm not drunk right now Betty botter
bought some butter but she said the
butter bitter if I put the batter it
will make my batter bitter but a bit of
better butter will make my batter better
so it was a better but Betty botter but
a bit of better butter Betty botter
bought some butter but she said the
butters bitter so if I put it in my
batter it will make my better my batter
bitter but a bit of better butter will
make my batter better so twas better
Betty botter bought a bit of better
butter Betty botter bought some butter
but she said the better butters bitter
if I put it in my batter it will make
the batter bitter but a bit of Betty
butter will make my batter better so it
was Betty botter that bought a bit of
better butter buddy butter but sorry
Betty botter bought some butter but she
said the butters bitter if I put it in
my batter it will make my batter bitter
but a bitter butter butter will make my
batter butter so it was but a better
buddy butter bought a better bit of
butter butter
liz is drawing liz yeah we had three
people to prepare
oh yeah they must continue it's too
early for this amount of strategy you
just have to do it really fast do it
really fast yeah it's like the
tablecloth oh wow what Seaport like a
oh no tablecloth yeah
oh my god I'm gonna send this to my mom
yeah I think it's fear I think really
yeah me okay yeah we're gonna lean on
each other was that a part of the test
those heels yeah it's hurting me already
yeah you really do have to think about
it don't you
[Music]
I did all right I did so well though
like I wasn't even yelled at oh it was
like she's drunk she's drunk no I think
I did pretty well I passed that z Y X W
u w vu
I know f e d c b a alright z WS
no z z y xw no a b c d e f and your
welcomes z w it
z XY no and they just stop okay z YW x
[Music]
okay my strategy is just be confident
and I'm just gonna say whatever I think
will come out cy x wi ll p q r s t u DC
ba she put it on my head
okay let's come here what's your
opposite yeah even me out there yeah I
think confidence to me always resist
wrong okay yeah that's true yeah maybe
I'm just like a brilliant part yeah true
that's more drunk but it doesn't is the
like those two know it's cuz I don't
know them really well I raise your hand
if you are
[Music]
[Music]
nice turn very endearing and sincere
about you that I feel like you'd be the
crazy drunk you're not that she'd be the
one that would cry is that true it's
true
[Music]